bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat pour la traditionnelle
la séance de questions cribles on prend
tout de suite la direction de
l'hémicycle où les sénateurs interpelle
aujourd'hui le ministre de la défense
jean yves le drian sur le thème de
l'europe de la défense
à tout à l'heure 15h45 climatiques
terrorisme cybercriminalité
aujourd'hui il est question de fixer un
seuil minimum de 1,5 pour cent du pipe
pour le budget de la défense française
monsieur le ministre c'est au niveau
européen qu'il faut se donner de tels
moyens en contribuant même hauteur de 2%
du pib' 1% pour la défense nationale 1 %
pour l'europe de la défense
cette europe de la défense pourrait être
l'occasion de proposer une nouvelle
approche de la gestion des conflits
en prenant en compte la dimension
environnementale des crises actuelles
la raréfaction des ressources
l'accroissement de la demande
énergétique
les changements climatiques ont des
conséquences sociales et économiques qui
auront nécessairement un impact majeur
dans les relations internationales
le développement durable est aujourd'hui
la donne et stratégiques à intégrer dans
notre réflexion sur la défense
l'ignorer serait une erreur majeure
monsieur le ministre
voilà ce qui doit aussi réorienter notre
réflexion à plusieurs reprises j'ai eu
l'occasion d'interpeller le gouvernement
sur ce que j'appelle l'écologisation de
la défense et en particulier
l'adaptation des missions de l'armée et
je conclus après la smart défense la
seule différence
la france doit être leader pour porter
au sein de l'europe
la green différence le président
hollande a affirmé lors de son
allocution devant le parlement européen
il est temps d'en finir avec la
dispersion des initiatives parce que
laurent l'oeil doit parler je finirai je
ne ne répliquent ray pas la question du
oui mais déjà dépassé le temps de re
plus finir à six questions en
conséquence monsieur ministres quels
sont les efforts concrets de notre
gouvernement pour relancer l'europe de
la défense
et à quand une grille des fans sur
remercie voilà merci beaucoup la parole
est à jean yves le drian ministre de la
défense
oui madame le président madame la
sénatrice mesdames et messieurs les les
sénateurs jeu
partage madame la sénatrice votre
enthousiasme pour la construction de
l'europe de la défense mais avant de
vous faire quelques observations à ce
sujet je voudrais m'inscrire en faux sur
le fait que la france soit seul au mali
et qu'elle n'y connaît l'europe ni amène
que des infirmières même si le mot peut
faire sourire et un peu provocateur la
réalité n'est pas celle là il y a
aujourd'hui 22 22 22 pays européens qui
participent à la mission de formation
initiée par l'union européenne ce qui
est un acte important s'était mise en
oeuvre rapidement et cette mission de
formation de reconstitution de l'armée
malienne commence à ces actions et ces
initiatives dès la semaine prochaine
et par ailleurs nous avons eu le soutien
de plusieurs pays européens dans la
logistique ce soit la grande bretagne le
danemark l'espagne l'italie l'allemagne
la belgique pour nous aider dans notre
intervention donc la france n'est pas
seule aujourd'hui au mali il n'empêche
que vous avez raison de souligner que
l'europe de la défense est encore en
friche et la nouvelle et la décision de
la part du président valente pas eu
d'organiser un conseil européen sur la
défense à la fin de l'année 2013 pour
relancer de l'ordre de défense est une
bonne initiative à laquelle nous nous
préparons activement
j'espère que pourra sortir de ce sommet
des actions nouvelles et fortes pour
renforcer l'europe de la défense
par contre sur votre volonté d'avoir un
pour cent du budget de la défense à
initiatives nationales et un pour cent
du budget de du produit du produit
intérieur brut
affecté à l'europe de la défense même si
cela part d'un point de vue très
optimiste je voudrais vous faire
observer que la l'europe de la défense
aujourd'hui la participation de la
france à l'euro de la défense que ce
soit au titre de l'europe de l'union
européenne que ce soit au titre du
pilier
la défense au sein de l'otan parce par
nos propres capacités donc que c'est un
pour cent ne s'additionnent pas de cette
manière
même si votre volonté tout à fait
louable merci donc avec votre permission
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
jean pierre chevènement pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous connaissons monsieur
ministre attachement à la défense
pas seulement à l'outil militaire mais à
la condition des hommes
vous avez su montrer votre proximité
avec nos soldats en vous préoccupant
directement des choses et plus
matérielles je pense au retard des
soldes ou à vos visites sur le terrain
notamment dans l'adrar des iforas
nombreux sont ceux qui sur ces bancs
connaissent les solutions budgétaires
très préoccupante de la défense face à
l'ampleur des coupes envisagées par le
ministère du budget vous avez le soutien
du sénat monsieur le ministre quasi
unanime pour dire qu'il n'est pas
possible de relâcher l'effort de défense
en dessous de un an et demi pour cent du
pipe soit environ 31 milliards d'euros
par an sans compromettre définitivement
la dépendance et la qualité de notre
outil de défense
nos soldats avec peu font merveille au
mali je salue leur professionnalisme
leur courage leur esprit de sacrifice
ils ont évité que le mali devienne un
sanctuaire d'aqmi
l'intervention décidée par le président
de la république françois hollande
correspond à l'intérêt de la france mais
aussi à celui de l'europe
or celle-ci n'apporte qu'un soutien
modeste à l'armée française engagés sur
le terrain
il en va de même pour la mission utm où
la france supporte 40 à 50% des missions
et des charges
monsieur le ministre vous avez souligné
en octobre 2012 devant l'assemblée
nationale je vous cite les contraintes
budgétaires représentent peut-être une
chance pour l'europe de la défense car
il faut éviter que l'europe de la
défense ne connaisse un déclassement
stratégique nous serions prêts à vous
suivre sur ce terrain monsieur le
ministre si un effort accru de
coopération à une mutualisation étaient
entrepris sans préjudice bien entendu
pour notre autonomie de décision
or quels sont les coopérations
free et les technologiques nouvelles qui
sont venus s'ajouter jeudi bien
s'ajouter monsieur mise depuis l'automne
dernier à celles déjà engagées et qui le
couvrent déjà qu'un chant très limité je
veux signer sisi t le programme mrtt
avions de ravitaillement en vol et de
transport dans les premières commandes
sont inscrits au budget 2013
l'avion de transport militaire à 4,3 100
m déjà commandé à 50 exemplaires dont la
première livraison devrait intervenir
fin 2013 les drones le watchkeeper à
quel horizon
ainsi vous pouviez nous répondre les
missiles pams pour les frégates
antiaériennes des missiles air air de
longue portée meteor déjà commandé à 200
exemplaires
le projet franco britannique de lindsey
en contraignant le temps dont nous
aimerions savoir s'il est maintenu et
financer le programme musis et radios
logicielles militaire magassa monsieur
milan ac coopération déjà engagés quels
autres sont venus s'ajouter
est-ce que les crédits nécessaires à la
mise en oeuvre des programmes seront
sauvegardées sanctuariser chez nous chez
les autres des démarches ont été
entreprises
en ce sens il est un moment où les mots
doivent recouvrir une réalité ou alors
il faut dire que la perspective d'une
défense européenne ne peut être une
perspective à très long terme
un susceptible de résoudre les problèmes
dans l'immédiat alors il faut compter
sur nous mêmes voilà monsieur le
ministre les questions auxquelles nous
aimerions entrant entendre des réponses
précises
merci chers collègues je ne pourrais pas
vous donner le temps de répliques car
vous avez vous l'avez utilisé dans la
question monsieur le ministre si vous
voulez bien répondre monsieur le
sénateur chevènement je voudrais
m'associer à vos propos concernant le
match que vous avez rendu aux soldats
français qui aujourd'hui mène des
actions une action exemplaire en termes
de courage mais aussi en termes de
tactique et de savoir faire militaire au
mali
jusqu'à encore cette nuit à tombouctou
les croix bleue le soutien de l'ensemble
de la nation à cette intervention est
aussi tout à fait important pour l'heure
leur moral et leur dynamisme
j'aurais aussi vous remercier les uns et
les autres par votre intermédiaire
monsieur le sénateur sur le fait que les
groupes politiques du sénat sont très
vigilants au moment où est en train de
se préparer la conclusion du livre blanc
et la préparation de la future loi de
programmation militaire et que vous
attachiez très vivement à au fait que la
dépense militaire française doit rester
autour de 1 5% du produit intérieur brut
c'est une position que j'apprécie avec
plaisir quant à la question que vous
avez posé sur la la coopération à venir
au niveau européen vous avez fait une
liste de coopération en cours et c'est
vrai que la mutualisation et la
coopération capacitaire est tout à fait
essentiel vous souhaitez savoir si
d'autres initiatives ont été prises
je dois pouvoir dire qu'il n'ya pas eu
de conclusions concrètes
d'autres projets depuis depuis le début
de l'année sauf à ce que a constaté
qu'il y à des avancées notables dans
deux ou trois domaines en particulier
dans le domaine des drones et dans le
domaine des chasseurs de mines qui nous
laisse à penser qu'on pourra avoir des
conclusions assez rapidement sur sur ces
deux sujets j'aurais vous dire aussi que
je ne crois pas que ce soit un chant
très limité vous avez fait une liste
d'équipements qui si on les ajoute les
uns aux autres correspondent à peu près
à 30% des investissements hors
dissuasion de la dépense
d'investissement en france qui est un
signe important et qui montre qu' il y à
une europe de la capacité de défense et
d'industrie défense qui est en route
même s'il est insuffisante à nos yeux
dans la préparation budgétaire futur et
dans la loi de programmation militaire à
venir
évidemment nous ferons tout pour
préserver les contractualisations que
nous avons passé avec nos voisins
européens
pour notre propre sécurité et pour la
leur merci
dix secondes monsieur le ministre avec
la permission de leila achi qui a
accepté pour la première question
merci le président simplement il y un
seuil en dessous duquel nous ne pouvons
pas descendre trois pins et demi pour
cent du pib
je suggère monsieur le ministre que le
surcroît de l'effort de dépenses de
défense
opérée par la france par rapport à la
moyenne européenne soit 0 5% du pib'
viennent en soustraction du plafond
déficit autorisé depuis maastricht soit
3% du pib
en dessous il ya une rupture de kiel et
de l' équilibre entre la france et
l'allemagne
le président landau certainement en être
conscient nous avons avoir un avantage
comparatif dont nous ne pouvons pas nous
défaire merci d'apple est à présent
monsieur philippe paul pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le premier
ministre a annoncé récemment que des
coupes budgétaires fortes étaient
indispensables afin de réduire notre
déficit public conformément aux
exigences de la commission européenne en
le ramenant en dessous des 3% du pib
ces coupes seraient évalués à près de 5
milliards d'euros
visiblement tous les ministères seraient
concernés par ce plan d'économies est le
budget de la défense ne serait pas
épargnée
on évoque ainsi de le ramener de 1,56 du
pipa 1,1
c'est sans précédent ceci provoque de
nombreux remous au sein de nos armées
voire un désarroi aussi bien auprès de
nos militaires que des personnels civils
et de l'industrie de la défense
ce serait tout simplement catastrophique
dans l'hypothèse d'un tel scénario
comment ne pas s'interroger sur le
maintien de la capacité opérationnelle
de nos armées accomplir leur mission
serait tout bonnement impossible et les
fondements mêmes de la défense nationale
voire de notre indépendance remis en
question ceci n'aurait plus de sens nous
n'aurions plus d'armée par ailleurs la
france est intervenue au mali sous
couvert de l'onu avec me semble-t-il le
feu vert des 26 autres pays de l'union
européenne alors que bruxelles demande
instamment à la france de ramener son
déficit public à moins de 3% du pib'
alors que la france est le seul pays
européen à avoir engagé des troupes au
sol
certes pour préserver notre pays d' acte
terroriste mais aussi l'europe dans son
ensemble
monsieur le ministre ne considérez vous
pas que la france doit exiger que ces
dépenses militaires figure hors
contingent des déficits publics ou à
tout le moins bénéficient d'un déficit
particulier nos partenaires européens
doivent comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
avoir l'armée française et la gratuité
de l'armée française
notre armée un coup il faut en accepter
les conséquences
ainsi dans le cadre des coupes
budgétaires prévues le ministère de la
défense pourrait ne pas impacter et
pourrait poursuivre efficacement sa
mission en préservant ses matériels ces
personnels civils et militaires et bien
évidemment son industrie de la défense
c'est aussi une question de crédibilité
de nos armes et du rayonnement
international et de la souveraineté de
la france je vous remercie
merci monsieur jean yves le drian
monsieur le sénateur vous avez raison de
rappeler le moment nous trouvons dans la
préparation du livre blanc et de la
future loi de programmation militaire
qui sera soumise aux assemblées
à l'automne il y a des moments de
d'arbitrage des discussions qui ont
toujours existé au moment de la
rédaction est l'aboutissement des lois
de programmation militaire
donc inévitablement des propos sortent
ici ou là dans la presse annonçant telle
ou telle situation particulièrement
difficile
j'ai connu sar sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale pendant de
nombreuses années
là je le connais de d'un autre point de
vue de la discussion il importe que nous
puissions sortir d'une difficulté
majeure qui consista à la fois assurer
notre souveraineté par la maîtrise de
notre dette et de nos finances publiques
est à la fois notre souveraineté par
l'existence d'une défense cohérente et
efficace et cela se traduit par des
chiffres c'est la difficulté à laquelle
nous nous heurtons en ce moment et il à
laquelle il faudra donner une un
arbitrage final dans les semaines qui
viennent
en tout cas votre proposition de qui
reprend en partie celle de sénateurs
chevènement il ya un instant de faire en
sorte que l'investissement de défense
précisément parce que c'est de
l'investissement ne soient pas intégrés
dans la comptabilité des déficits
publics au niveau européen a toute ma
sympathie mais je ne suis pas en
situation de pouvoir vous répondre ni à
l'un ni à l'autre mais il y a une
cohérence dans le propos jeu j'espère
que le fait qu'il y ait un conseil
européen de défense à la fin de cette
année permettra de poser réellement la
place de l'investissement de défense
dans l'ensemble de la dette européenne
et son efficacité en termes de sécurité
mais aussi de développement économique
eh bien merci monsieur philippe paul
merci donc la parole est à présent à
monsieur jean marie bockel pour le
groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants us et 1 10% de nos
compatriotes adhèrent à l'idée d'une
coopération européenne plus étroite en
matière de défense et on sait que dans
le contexte de crise économique de
réduction des budgets de dépenses que
nous vivons un peu partout en europe
le renforcement des capacités militaires
de l'union européenne semble très très
opportun la création de l' agence de
défense en 2004 pour harmoniser nos
efforts de défense a constitué une
avancée avec l'idée d'un partage d'une
mutualisation de ses efforts et avec des
projets décisif
jean pierre chevènement cité notamment
les avions ravitailleurs dont on voit
ces temps-ci l'utilité c'est un exemple
positif il en faudrait d'autres
simplement cette agence européenne
elles rencontrent des obstacles père
permanent et persistants notamment son
budget qui est modeste cantonné à 30
millions d'euros et qui stagne depuis
trois ans le renforcement des capacités
de l'union est pourtant primordiale au
moins à deux titres tout d'abord
l'industrie de défense c'est pas une
industrie que les autres en raison de sa
dimension stratégique
en effet sans une solide base
industrielle et technologique de défense
l'europe risque fort de voir s'éroder
son indépendance stratégique et aussi sa
capacité d'influencé sur la scène
internationale avec les valeurs propres
que nous partageons en outre le
potentiel de développement et de
création d'emplois et c'est important en
temps de crise est considérable dans ce
secteur il suffit de faire le parallèle
avec l'industrie aérospatiale et les
tables succès européen pour voir le
potentiel que nous avons je pense
également à de nombreuses opportunités
dans le domaine de la cyber défense
hautement stratégique est en croissance
exponentielle alors il va y avoir le
conseil européen de défense en décembre
prochain sur ces question pouvez vous
nous indiquer monsieur le ministre et à
ceux ci yves pozzo di borgo qui suit ces
questions de défense européenne à lui d
i
quelles sont les propositions mises sur
la table pour améliorer la coopération
européenne en matière capacitaire
comment la france nation cadre en
matière de défense et qui entend le
rester je l'espère en tout cas
peut-être soutenir les grands projets
structurants favoriser les
rapprochements industriels
enfin qu'en est-il d'un rapproche d'un
renforcement espérer des moyens
matériels et humains de cette agence
européenne dont d'ailleurs la présidente
la directrice est une compatriote
merci monsieur le ministre très bien
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur bockel je partage complètement
votre soutien et votre appréciation à
l'égard de l'agencé européenne de
défense c'est un outil important ce
n'est pas une agence de programme c'est
l'eau car qui rompuy ce rôle mais c'est
un outil de coopération capacitaires et
qui essaye de faire converger
l'expression des besoins opérationnels
des états et c'est un outil qui a fait
la preuve de son efficacité quand on le
saisit il ya une difficulté que vous
avez soulevés qui est le fait que le
budget de l'agencé européenne de défense
reste très modeste 30 millions d'euros
par an que vous avez rappelé ce budget
n'est par évaluer alors qu'ils le
devraient l'être pour faire face à ses
compétences et à ses missions et pas
dévaluer parce qu'il y a à chaque
réunion du conseil de l'agencé
économique de
robben de l'agencé européenne de défense
il ya à chaque fois un blocage de la
part de la représentation britannique et
il ya encore quelques semaines je les
constate et moi même j'espère là aussi
que le conseil européen de décembre sera
en mesure de donner à l'agencé
européenne de défense un nouveau souffle
pour ma part je souhaite que ce conseil
européen de défense a en décembre
prochain ne soit pas une seule
apparition
cinq ans après que dernier conseil
européen ne se soit occupé de questions
de défense mais qu'il y ait l'engagement
d'une échéance annuelle qui soit
l'occasion d'aborder les questions de
défense par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens et je souhaite
que à l'occasion de ce prochain conseil
il puisse y avoir une véritable avancée
pratiques et non pas théorique de
l'europe de l'est face de la défense à
la fois dans le domaine opérationnel en
particulier dans la manière de gérer les
crises deuxièmement en matière de
partage capacitaires et dalal agence
européenne de défense peut jouer un rôle
essentiel et puis troisième en termes de
définition de ce qu'est le souk de
l'industrie de défense et les
technologies de défense en europe et de
la manière de renforcer ses capacités et
de renforcer de renforcer les
initiatives autour de ce souk industriel
voilà sur quelle base nous travaillons
aujourd'hui nous voulons que ce débat
est que ces orientations soient
pragmatiques et efficaces et que ce soit
pas uniquement un coup d'épée dans l'eau
à un moment donné de l'histoire de
l'europe
très bien merci monsieur jean marie
bockel monsieur le président je crois de
belles potentialités en matière de
rapprochement de nos industries de
défense je cite l exemple de la
cyberdéfense en plein développement où
un certain nombre d'entreprises
européennes gagnerait notamment sur
certains équipements sensibles à
travailler ensemble je pourrais citer de
manière plus rustique peut-être en
matière de munitions une entreprise
comme manurhin que je connais bien
puisqu'elle est à mulhouse et qui est
déjà associé à d
capitaux minoritaires slovaque qui
pourrait s'associer avec d'autres
entreprises en belgique ou ailleurs et
là aussi constitué un fleuron une
dernière remarque la commission notre
commission de la défense des affaires
étrangères et le président carrère a
récemment pris l'initiative avec le
soutien de la quasi totalité du groupe
de vous soutenir
monsieur le ministre un dans votre
bataille 1 pour que notre budget
plusieurs collègues quand évoqués ne
tombe pas en dessous de 1,5 point du pib
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
et je voulais profiter de cette réponse
pour appeler ma détermination et notre
détermination à vous soutenir dans cette
bataille avant arbitrage très bien et
bien la parole est à présent monsieur
daniel renner pour le groupe socialiste
apparentés pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre est
d'abord en prêt à l'as profité de
l'occasion que nous sommes dans
l'hémicycle pour au nom de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense
vous remercier de votre disponibilité
vous vos collaborateurs pour nous rendre
compte en permanence des opérations qui
sont conduites actuellement au mali ma
question est double
récemment le président de la république
a participé à varsovie à une préparation
au conseil européen
il y est question d'améliorer
naturellement à l'occasion du conseil
européen de décembre l'efficacité de
cette politique de sécurité et de
défense commune de renforcer des
capacités militaires et d'améliorer si
c'est possible les performances de
l'industrie européenne
c'est sur ce sujet que je voudrais vous
vous interrogez nous savons tous que
nous ne pourrons plus de manière
unilatérale conduire des programmes
d'armement majeurs
en clair nous ne recevrons plus l'avion
de combat seul que nous avons fait avec
le rafale le risque c'est que les
européens et les français naturellement
achètent à l'étranger s'il ne s'associe
pas et ceci se fera évidemment des aux
dépens de notre dépendance stratégique
et de notre recherche et développent
je note que et on note malheureusement
que depuis 2000 à peu près il n'y a plus
un seul programme majeur d'armement en
coopération c'est bien dommage et je
vais vous poser une question et c'est en
même temps une suggestion
nous avons sur les drones échec
industriel pas tant européens et
français passer quelques accords entre
agences d'armement entre états
d'ailleurs et entre entreprises
industrielles avec les britanniques sur
le cas avec les allemands sur le droit
de mal tout ça me paraît pas très
claires et je suggère ma question est la
suivante
n'y at il pas là un sujet essentiel pour
lancer un grand programme européen sur
les drones de demain et en incidente
actuellement l'union européenne et les
etats-unis discutent d'une d'un accord
de libre échange
êtes vous sûr que les industries
d'armement ne soit pas concernée par le
sujet si elle si monsieur le sénateur
vous êtes arrivé au terme de votre
question pardon de vous couper plus bas
alors continué quelques secondes si vous
souhaitez très bien merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur énergie
dray pour m'assurer de d'avoir le temps
de répondre à ce point commencé par vos
interrogations sur l'accord de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et les
etats unis pour les choses soient
claires et pour que les choses sont
encore plus clair permettez-moi de le
dire ce que je vais vous dire la
commission a annoncé la semaine dernière
son intention d'engager là négociation
d'un accord de libre échange avec les
états unis
nous avons appris à ce moment là que la
commission prévoyait d'inclure le
secteur de la défense dans le périmètre
des négociations commerciales ce qui
constituerait un précédent des échanges
ont eu lieu dans la journée de mardi
sur ce sujet entre les échanges
interministériel entre différends
internes à la france et entre différents
gouvernements et ils conduisent à ce
stade à un consensus sur l'opportunité
d'exclure le secteur de la défense du
champ de cet accord mais mes services en
par ailleurs saisi les industriels
concernés pour recueillir leurs analyses
sur une telle perspective
et hier les industriels concernés
confirmait l'opportunité d'une telle
exclusion sur laquelle nous travaillons
donc en ce moment je voudrais c'était un
point important qui nécessitait cette
précision
je voudrais revenir sur juge acquis déjà
été évoquée par plusieurs auparavant
concernant les programmes industriels
européens
c'est vrai qu'il y a aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas eu de nouveaux grands programmes
de coopération à plusieurs états qui a
été engagée depuis quelques temps et
c'est vrai aussi que certains sujets
devrait pouvoir permettre demain une
coopération industrielle nouvelle
vous avez évoqué la génération future
aéronautique pour aller vite en parlant
de l'ucav qui était faite avec les
britanniques et non pas avec des
allemands sur le juste point
d'observation
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
travaillons nous devons passer un accord
de recherche amont avec les britanniques
sur cette question et vous avez évoqué
aussi les drones
alors vous savez sur les drones il y a
un manque capacitaire en particulier sur
les drones male donc sur les drones de
moyenne altitude amant capacitaire réel
pour notre pays mais aussi pour un
certain nombre de pays voisins je pense
en particulier à la grande-bretagne et à
l'allemagne voire même à l'italie nous
avons deux étapes à franchir la première
qui est celle d'acquérir des drones
selon a sérieusement désolé de
vous interrompre sur des questions aussi
importantes mais voilà si vous pouviez
c'est une bonne idée si vous pouvez le
reconnaître dans une autre question
c'est une bonne idée à la fois mais on
est dans le drone non pas intérimaire b
dans le drone pérenne il y a là un sujet
de discussion potentiel parfait et très
bien je vous remercie je peux donc passé
la parole à madame michèle de l'austin
mais comme un chat collègues une fusion
entre eads et bae systems aurait pu être
un exemple concret de constitution d'un
groupe européen de défense qui relancent
l'europe de la défense dont le président
de la république a fait l'une de ses
priorités
en effet la france et le royaume uni qui
représentent la moitié de l'effort
militaire européen et les deux tiers des
budgets de recherche avait estimé pour
optimiser les dépenses qu'il fallait
rationaliser et coordonner leurs efforts
cette fusion n'a pas pu aboutir car
hélas il ne s'agissait pas véritablement
de mutualisation dit de coopération en
réalité l'allemagne la grande bretagne
l'espagne et la france se sont opposés
sur des intérêts stratégiques
industriels et financiers divergent
ainsi une sortie partielle des groupes
lagardère et dallaire du capital de eads
entraîné une renégociation du pacte d
actionnaires publics qui s'est fait
malheureusement au détriment de notre
pays et qui a renforcé sur tout le poids
des actionnaires privés dans le capital
du groupe et je dirais à la grande
satisfaction du pdg d' eads thomas
enders qui ne manquent pas à toute
occasion de déclarer et on l'a entendu
plusieurs fois qu'il n'était pas
favorable à l'actionnaire à
l'actionnariat d'état la décision
d'entériner cette modification de la
structure du capital et la nouvelle
gouvernance qui en découle devrait être
prise le 27 mars lors d'une assemblée
générale extraordinaire des actionnaires
du groupe
je souhaiterais donc savoir monsieur le
ministre si les représentants de l'état
vont approuver
sans réagir ces modifications qui me
semblent contraires à la protection de
nos intérêts en matière de défense
nationale
merci c'était parfait au niveau du temps
la parole est à monsieur le ministre
jean yves le drian bien madame la
sénatrice vous avez rappelé la manière
dont les relations entre le groupe ads c
-b à eux avaient abouti à un échec nous
avions travaillé en profondeur sur cette
question nous avions même de notre côté
bien progressé sur la structuration
actionnariale les garanties industriels
et les garanties en matière d'emploi
ainsi que sur nos propres intérêts en
matière de défense je pense en
particulier à la dissuasion nous avions
eu une mauvaise j'avais autour d'une des
relations très étroites avec le ministre
allemand et le ministre britannique de
la défense mais il ya eu d'autres
relations à un plus haut niveau et nous
avions nous semble-t-il en tout cas de
notre côté réussi à faire converger des
positions mais les entreprises ont jugé
que ce n'était pas possible de faire
converger à la fois les positions des
états et les principaux actionnaires et
donc il y a eu un échec et à la suite de
cet échec que les parties se sont
mobilisés pour résoudre les principaux
problèmes de gouvernance eads en un
temps record et c'est dans ce cadre qu'a
été conclu en décembre les accords de
restructuration de l'actionnariat
eads ces accords permettent la sortie
des actionnaires historiques
daimler et lagardère sans déstabiliser
le groupe la constitution d'un noyau
d'actionnaires soudée autour de la
france l'allemagne l'espagne la
protection du groupe des prises de
contrôle hostile
la normalisation de la gouvernance du
groupe et le renforcement de la
protection de nos propres actifs et en
particulier des actifs de souveraineté
liés à la dissuasion qui seront protégés
dans une filiale sur laquelle nous
disposons de droits renforcés et en
fonction de ses avancées
nous considérons que les principes de
restructuration acté par les
actionnaires pourront être validés à
l'assemblée générale du 27 mars prochain
à laquelle vous faisiez référence que si
tu considères que eads va bien même sans
la fusion avec b a eu et je me félicite
que nous puissions franchir le cap
délicat de la restructuration en
préservant les intérêts de la france
l'homme devait s'y nouent souhaité
réagir
non je vous remercie la parole est à
présent monsieur françois noël buffet
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'europe de la défense est
impossible à construire si nous n'avons
pas une défense nationale crédible
mercredi dernier dans cet hémicycle le
groupe ump du sénat s'est associée sans
réserve à l'initiative nécessaire et
réussit d'ailleurs du président carrère
afin de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé et
d'interpeller le président de la
république sur les terribles danger que
représenterait des coupes budgétaires
pour nos armées et pour notre pays à la
veille d'un conseil national de défense
qui assombrit profondément l'avenir de
nos armées et menace notre outil de
défense
comment plaider auprès des états de
l'union européenne pour qu'ils
investissent dans celle ci
si nous mêmes nous utilisons notre
défense comme variable d'ajustement
budgétaire et pourquoi au final réaliser
des économies de quelques millions
certes motivé peut-être par un caractère
immédiat des choses la défense et est et
demeure l'un des derniers leviers de
notre croissance
il faut rappeler que ce secteur nous
apportent des milliards à l'export il
représente près de 400000 emplois
hautement qualifiés et peu
délocalisables
il est porté par un tissu industriel de
très nombreuses pme dont un de vos
collègues du gouvernement nous rabâche
qu'il veut doubler leur nombre
comment parler d'europe de la défense
alors que nous sommes en train
d'hypothéquer peut-être notre
indépendance stratégique
comment parler d'europe de la défense
alors que nous sommes à l'ultime limite
du décrochage capacitaire qui
entraînerait la perte de notre
souveraineté
enfin monsieur le ministre
si le président de la république a pu
engager les troupes françaises au mali
et dire même jusqu'à dire même le 2
février dernier que le plus beau jour
c'était le plus beau jour de sa vie
politique qui en étant à tombouctou
c'est parce qu'il disposait d'une
capacité de projection et d'un outil de
défense qui le lui permettait ce sont
les moyens budgétaires allouées
aujourd'hui qui gagent rond notre
présence dans le monde de demain
la réalité ma chemise c'est que
certaines nations sont des moteurs pour
l'europe de défense et c'est le cadre de
la france lorgne l'heure n'est pas à la
complainte mais à l'action et la
responsabilité
il vous revient à vous et nous savons
que vous en être convaincu de ne pas
céder aux pressions hypothécaire de
bercy qui annihilerait les 50 ans
d'efforts de construction européenne et
militaire que notre pays a consenti et
doit continuer de faire monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais savoir au nom
de mon groupe
c'est d'après midi de quels arguments et
de quels moyens
vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour
convaincre le président de la république
de ne pas soumettre le budget de notre
défense un rabot qui serait sans doute
quelque part extrêmement dangereux merci
monsieur jean yves le drian
le sénateur quoi je dispose de ma
conviction et de la vôtre j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire tout à l'heure que
je remerciais le sénat de ses prises de
position concernant le maintien d'un
effort significatif de défense pour
notre sécurité
je ne vais pas vous comprenez bien à ce
moment anticiper sur les conclusions
d'un processus qui est loin d'être
achevée et qui nécessitera des
arbitrages difficiles
je voudrais simplement rappeler j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure au sénateur paul
combien l'équation était
délicate entre la nécessité d'assurer la
souveraineté de notre pays par la
maîtrise de sa dette parce que c'est
aussi un élément de souveraineté quand
un pays est à la merci de ses créanciers
il n'a plus de souveraineté mais en même
temps il est indispensable de garder une
capacité sécuritaire au significative et
donc la souveraineté passe aussi par un
effort de défense significatif c'est le
sujet qui est qui est sur la table à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un livre blanc
et où une loi de programmation militaire
des questions de ce type sont revenus
elles sont encore plus difficile
maintenant cuillère pour pour des
raisons monsieur c'est nathan la
première et n'y voyait pas du tout
polémique c'est que la loi de
programmation antérieure n'a pas été
respectée pour une raison très simple et
je ne polémique pas non plus sur ce
sujet c'est quelle avait été établi
avant la crise et donc la projection qui
avait été initié dans la loi de
programmation 2009 2014 est une
projection qui n'a tenu que deux ans
quand je suis arrivé de ne pas de
responsabilité il manquait déjà selon la
cour des comptes mais j'ai constaté que
l avez raison 4 milliards par rapport à
l'autre la trajectoire et puis ensuite
il y a les difficultés du moment et la
nécessité d'atteindre les 3% de déficit
budgétaire à la fin de l'année 2014
voilà les contraintes
moi je souhaite être suffisamment
persuasifs pour que nous puissions
maintenir un effort de défense nous
permettant d'avoir des forces armées
cohérente et efficace
si vous le souhaitez vous avez trente
secondes de moins que monsieur le
président en 30 secondes simplement pour
dire à monsieur le ministre que l'on
entend ce qu'ils deviennent dire est
qu'il trouvera du côté de ces bancs un
soutien infaillible dans la défense de
son budget afin de donner à nos armes et
les moyens nécessaires permettant
simplement de rappeler que monsieur
cameron annoncé que les ministères chez
lui vers une diminution des budgets de
1% mais que la défense bénéficiera elle
d'un report de crédit non utilisées
gageons que cet exemple là puissent nous
servir dans les semaines qui viennent
merci monsieur merci la parole à andré
vallini pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
alors que le monde réarme l'europe
semble s'apprêter à désarmer
confrontés à la crise économique et donc
à celles de leurs finances publiques la
plupart des pays européens réduisent
leurs budgets de la défense et si elle
continue dans cette voie l'europe risque
un véritable déclassement stratégique
pour reprendre l'expression d'hubert
védrine
elle risque de sortir de l'histoire en
raison de la réorientation stratégique
des usa vers l'asie pacifique l'europe
ne peut plus tout attendre des états
unis en matière de défense
d'autant que et contrairement à ce que
pense trop souvent les opinions
publiques les menaces et les dangers
n'ont pas disparu bien au contraire
le moment semble donc venu de relancer
l'europe de la défense et au risque de
sembler paradoxal je pense que c'est au
moment où la construction européenne
traverse la crise de confiance la plus
grave de son histoire qu'il faut
relancer la défense européenne
en effet si l'on cumule l'ensemble des
moyens militaires
les 27 pays membres l'europe dispose
d'un million cinq cent mille soldats et
275 milliards d'euros de budget on
imagine facilement les économies que
nous pourrions tous réalisés en
mutualisant ses forces
or aucun pays mieux que la france peut
le faire peut s'engager dans cette
démarche a fortiori depuis que la france
a réintégré le commandement militaire de
l'otan
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
cela a été dit plusieurs fois avant moi
le conseil européen de décembre prochain
est une occasion unique de relancer
l'europe de la défense je souhaiterais
donc savoir
dans cette perspective qu'elle est votre
priorité aux quelles sont vos priorités
priorité institutionnels priorités
industrielles ou priorités
opérationnelles
je vous remercie merci monsieur jean
yves le drian
je vais venir monsieur le sénateur
directement à la fin de votre de votre
propos je pense qu'il serait peu et peu
efficace d'aborder les mutations
indispensables et la relance de l'europe
de la défense par la question
institutionnelle
parce que cela a déjà échoué
et que si nous abordions en particulier
si la france abordait le débat qui
s'ouvre maintenant tant mieux du moment
où il y a ce conseil européen à la fin
de l'année par cette question
nous risquerions d'être en difficulté je
vous rappelle les déboires de l'eau hq
antérieurement de la mise en oeuvre d'un
quartier général européen qui avait été
bloquée qui a provoqué un certain
enlisement
nous voulons aborder cette question de
manière pragmatique en déclinant je le
crois l'avoir dit déjà tout à l'heure à
la fois sur le côté gestion des crises
ou opérationnelles à la fois sûre dans
le domaine capacitaires et dans le
domaine de l'industrie
toute une série d'initiatives concrètes
et réalisables
sinon désespéra tout concept d'europe de
la défense c'est ce qu'a souhaité public
c'est ce que j'ai repris à plusieurs
reprises et je sens apparaître quelques
frémissements qui pour aller en ce sens
alors sur les crises et sur les
opérations il ya déjà eu des progrès
contrairement à ce que certains ont dit
je considère que l'opération du mali au
niveau de l'ue l'europe de la défense
est un progrès parce qu'il y à une
initiative européenne qui aboutit à ce
qu'il y ait 500 militaires européens sur
le sol malien dès à présent pour former
une nouvelle armée malienne et donc il
ya donc des militaires européens au sol
c'est pas parfait mais c'est une
initiative nouvelle et je pense que
demain il dira des interrogations et des
actions à mener peut-être pas sous la
même forme dans en libye et aussi dans
la région des balkans pour reprendre
l'initiative dans le nord kosovo de la
même dans le même état d'esprit le
pragmatisme concernera aussi les
capacités il a été dit tout à l'heure
que dans le secteur du ravitaillement en
vol il y avait eu des des progrès
d'autres secteurs importants peuvent
faire l'objet de coopération très
concrète et mises en oeuvre rapidement
et sur l'industrie
je sais que la commission prépare une
communication sur la coopération
industrielle en matière de défense pour
le mois de mai qui servira de base à la
préparation du conseil européen tout ça
est une bonne chose je rajoute un
dernier point très brièvement que le
concept de coopération structurée
permanente
qui avait un peu disparu des radars si
je peux prendre une expression militaire
est en train de revenir progressivement
et il est inscrit dans le traité de
lisbonne et il pourrait peut-être
réapparaître au cours des mois prochains
et pour aboutir à peut-être des
initiatives au moment de du conseil
européen de fin d'année
merci merci mon cher collègue
merci d'avoir cédé votre temps à
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent à monsieur rené
beaumont pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues et
maintenant il ya maintenant deux buts
deux ans que la france et la grande
bretagne ont signé un partenariat de
défense historique ce 31ème sommet
franco-britannique a permis de raviver
l'esprit du sommet de saint malo en 98
et les accords de lancaster house furent
une formidable occasion d'impulser une
vraie dynamique en matière de
coopération militaire qui rime avec
mutualisation en période de crise et
face au manque d'attraction pour la
défense de la part des autres membres
autres pays membres de l'union
économique l'union européenne
ce type de course de coopération
bilatérale constitue un exemple et même
plus un moteur pour l'avenir la défense
européenne
bien sûr sur le terrain en termes
d'opérations extérieures l'europe et la
défendre l'europe de la défense se fait
de plus en plus attendre et les exemples
libyen et maliens se passe de
commentaires pour démontrer l'inertie
européenne mais versé dans
l'euroscepticisme aujourd'hui en matière
de défense et une est d'une telle
facilité politique et intellectuel que
nous devons nous y refuser la france et
la grande bretagne sont les deux
contributeurs de loin les plus
importants de l'otan'' après les états
unis et assureront d'ici à moins de 10
ans près de 65 % des dépenses de défense
de l'union européenne
ces deux nations atomique qui partagent
la même vision en termes de dissuasion
nucléaire sont encore sont encore les
rares défense nationale au sein de
l'union européenne
qui demeure mondialement crédible aussi
monsieur le ministre nous espérons que
le conseil de défense de vendredi ne
m'allait rap animé modeste propos ni
encore moins le travail réalisé par nos
deux pays depuis la signature des
accords de lancaster house ces
engagements sont des références en
matière de coopération structurelle
renforcer les objectifs des deux traités
qui en découlent grâce à la
mutualisation nous permettent déjà de
dégager des économies annuelles à
hauteur de 150 millions par an mieux
cette coopération militaire s'accompagne
d'une coopération parlementaire grâce
l'engagement du président jocelyn route
d'oran une véritable collaboration entre
notre commission et nos homologues
allemands s'est instauré initiative que
bien sûr le président jean louis carrère
poursuit désormais très activement comme
lui qu'il faut poser la question je
termine tout de suite et qui fait
l'unanimité de notre commission
en ces temps difficiles c'est consensus
devrait inspirer le gouvernement à
poursuivre le dialogue franco
britannique seul capable aujourd'hui de
créer la véritable ébauche de robes de
défense mon souci vous l'avez compris
monsieur ministre et de connaître
l'avenir que vous réservez au fameux 30
traité de lancaster house
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur merci de cette question ça me
permet de rejoindre le point de vue que
vous développez et de dire de vous dire
que la la coopération franco-britannique
structuré dans le cadre des accords de
lancaster house se poursuit de manière
positive
ça me permet indirectement de répondre à
monsieur buffet je ne sais pas si les il
est parti mais vous lui direz que
faisait l'éloge de monsieur cameron que
monsieur commandes d'année dernière
avait fait baisser le budget de la
défense britannique de 2 8% et je
suggère cela pour sa méditation du
week-end mais
donc c'est relativement facile
aujourd'hui de rétablir la situation
je voudrais vous dire aussi que le
traité de lancaster house à présente un
avantage
une singularité nouvelle puisqu'il
comporte un volet nucléaire
c'est une avancée significative de la
coopération avec le royaume uni
mais au-delà de cela nous nous
progressons de manière intelligente et
loyale sur l'ensemble du dispositif qui
a été signé par exemple la force
expéditionnaire commune interarmées la
cjp ef est en cours de constitution et
elle atteindra son côté opérationnel
plein en 2016 nous avons initié en
matière opérationnelle des exercices
communs dont d'un très gros c'est un
exercice très important en présence des
deux ministres de la défense en octobre
dernier et nous mettons en place des
intérêts opérabilité de systèmes
d'information de communication et le
partage du renseignement au delà de cela
nous avons aussi initié une coopération
sous ma responsabilité en matière de
drones à la fois les drones de théâtre
watchkeeper mais aussi les drones de
générations futures luc havre en
particulier que c'est des signes de
coopération très très actif je ne parle
pas du drone mâle dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure je parle que d autres extrême en
petit en très grand des technologies du
futur et nous avons aussi une
collaboration très étroite en matière de
guerre des mines et nous avons transféré
à l'eau car cette responsabilité et sous
une le patronage d'une équipe franco
britannique dans les relations sont
bonnes elles ne sont pas exclusives et
nous disons aux britanniques que nous
avons une relation bonne avec eux mais
que ce nous empêche pas d'avoir des
relations avec le groupe de weimar où
avec le groupe devise grade puisqu'il ya
eu une réunion commune des mises la
défense de ces ensembles régionaux
il y a peu de temps il faut que ce soit
dans la transparence et qu'on dise à
chacun ce que l'on fait avec l'autre
pour éviter les incompréhensions voire
les grincements qui ont pu se produire
dans le passé vous avez raison de dire
que c'est parce que nous aurons une
coopération capacitaire que nous
pourrons aboutir à une gestion plus
économe des de l'argent public rare en
cette période que ce soit en grande
bretagne ou en france
merci on vous remercie monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec la séance des questions
cribles je vais suspendre la séance
elles soient reprises à 16h pour la
suite du projet de loi de séparation et
de régulation des activités bancaires la
séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles consacré à l'europe de la
défense jean yves le drian devant les
sénateurs le ministre de la défense a
rappelé que la france n'était pas seule
au mali mais il a concédé bien que cette
europe de la défense resté en friche
le ministre de la défense qui a par
ailleurs été interpellés sur le budget
des armées beaucoup de sénateurs ont
plaidé pour que le budget de la défense
ne tombe pas en deçà du seuil des 1 5%
du pib
réponse du ministre il faut attendre les
arbitrages qui seront rendus à l'automne
à l'occasion de l'examen de la loi de
programmation militaire
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire c'est ce soir à 19 heures
avec le journal présenté par michel
grossiord bonne fin de journée à tous
bien